this is the Jocko underground podcast
it's number 52.
sitting here with Echo Charles EC in the
house
I was out at Gettysburg we're doing the
the echelon front Battlefield doing the
battlefield walk and I I went on this
little
kind of like
tangent
not only a tangent a ref maybe you know
what you've seen me do this kind of
thing like going off about something you
digressed a little bit no it's not a
digression it's not a digression wait
like what is bad right the aggression
leads us nowhere it's a positive well
not necessarily I think technically
digression just means like you're going
in One Direction with a whatever and
then you win digression different
indicates we're not moving in a good
direction though like oh but I digress
then I have to get back to something
let's say the initial Direction but sure
so I
diverted my comments and anyways we were
talking about terrain you know you're
out there on the battlefield you can see
like high ground and low ground and how
important it is and impactful it is and
then I kind of went on this explaining
that people are Terrain
because there's some real similarities
between people and terrain because you
if you if you're a good Battlefield
leader you can look at the terrain and
you can figure out how best to use it
and how it's use it to your advantage
and how it's going to help you win the
battle there also you can't look at um a
hill on on the map or on the ground and
be like hey I don't really like the way
this hill is I'm gonna move the hill you
can't do that yeah yeah that's true you
have to utilize the terrain so people
are like Terrain in that they got some
advantages to them you know this guy's
really really smart at math cool where
am I going to put them accounting
department right you know this person's
uh really enjoys conversation with
people where I'm gonna put him sales
department right so so you have Terrain
and people are terrain and you can't
look look can you change them a little
bit over time sure
but
they're not going to change a hundred
percent you can you can make some small
they're not even gonna change you're
lucky to get someone to change you know
15 20 percent
they can change important important
difference they can change so if you
Echo Charles like the classic cases
let's say you hit rock bottom yeah if
you hit rock bottom you can change you
can be like I'm never taking drugs again
I'm never do whatever whatever made you
hit rock bottom you're gambling you're
drinking whatever thing was you can
change it but I can't change you oh it's
very difficult for me to change you
let's say you are a micromanager
I can move you a little bit I can I can
get you to micromanage less but unless
you say you know what man I am a
micromanager and I know it's not good
I'm gonna change then that's different
then we can make some real progress
that's why one of the key factors of
what I try and do when I work with
people is not me impose the truth onto
them but show them what they're doing so
they go you know what I feel like I'm
micromanaging my team and I go yeah you
know that probably probably feels like
that to them you know so we so it gets
they see it themselves then they want to
change
so
what I I ended up talking I mean I'm
talking about this quite a bit lately is
understanding what Tendencies people
have right so that's what we have to do
we have to read the terrain of our
people is this person a micromanager is
this person obsessed with details does
this person not care about details
because if I'm like got a critical
a part of a project that relies on
excruciating detail I'm not putting Echo
Charles in Charge of that project right
that's not your thing it's not your
detailed thing if I have something
that's going to require a creative
solution then maybe I'm like hey I'm
gonna put echo on this thing because
he's going to have to see the vision and
create something that that people will
feel okay well that's an echo Charles
thing so I've got to know and understand
what your tendency is
are you too emotional
and if you're too emotional I've got a
I've got a not only assign you into
positions where those emotions will be
mitigated but I've also got to think oh
we're about to echo's about to get some
bad news about the project
I need to go down there and make sure
that he stays under control
maybe you're too analytical right where
you're walking around like a robot and
that something's going wrong with the
team and they're all upset and you're
just like I don't know what the problem
is let's move forward you know and then
you losing connection with your team and
that's a problem
maybe you're too aggressive maybe you're
not aggressive enough so we can go
through all these different traits
but what's important for me as a leader
is just like I read the terrain on out
on the battlefield hey here's some high
ground
here's some low ground here's a ravine I
can utilize this for dead space as we
approach the target like all those
things that I'm gonna study about the
train I have to try and understand that
about my people too
so
that makes sense right you understand
you're tracking
what'd you write down over there you got
commentary no no uh you kind of covered
it though after I wrote it down oh you
you know you name all these traits right
and then you're like okay you don't
think of it in terms of like oh I hate
that they're like that and and they need
to change or whatever it's like you got
to kind of work around it or over it or
even utilize it really yes in a lot of
ways so if let's say someone's um like a
big one is like stubborn right someone's
like stubborn yeah so the wrong way to
think about it is the initial thought
that that when you're talking ahead or
whatever
where if they're stubborn like it's so
frustrating when someone's stubborn and
they don't want to budge on something
but it doesn't have to be frustrating if
you look at it in terms of hey it's just
it's like a mountain it's like you're
trying to do signing or something the
mouse is in the way it's like you
getting frustrated that there's a
mountain there but that doesn't help you
at all yeah you got to focus on what you
should do you know how do you maneuver
kind of thing so two things on that the
there's a famous operation in Vietnam
that the seals did where they scaled a
cliff to get to the Target and no the
enemy never thought that anyone would
ever scale this clip so it's
exactly what you're saying hey here's
this cliff
it seems impassable guess what we're
going to utilize it you have someone
that's really stubborn oh you have a
project that you know is going to take a
hard nose to get through this project
and get everything done maybe that's the
person you assigned and I'll tell you
another thing that's interesting
with your kids you know and you think oh
my kid's so stubborn okay what is how is
that a positive quality because it is a
positive quality you know you could say
stubborn you can also use a different
word determined those are almost the
same words right yeah those are almost
the same words hey Won't Give Up keeps
going won't won't compromise on this
that's determination so how do we as a
parent as a leader
find the best way to utilize the human
terrain and put people in a position
where they're going to be successful and
they're going to help the mission
um
so that's part one
part two
straight out of Sun Tzu you gotta
understand your own
Tendencies you've got to understand your
own terrain you gotta know what you are
and who you are in life and as a leader
you gotta recognize when you're 16 years
old that you fall for girls too quick
you go head over heels right
or you fall for guys too quick you gotta
realize that you gotta say oh I get this
feeling and I feel like I'm way out of
control and I feel like I'm
way too
in the game and supportive and on board
with this per with with people I get
around you get hyped on them yeah
so you gotta you gotta calculate that uh
are you too quick to judge others are
you too trusting that's a big one
you just try hey that sounds good right
your can be too trusting you got to know
that and this is really
you can start to recognize these things
like I wish somebody would have said
this to me when I was 15. because you
can start recognizing this stuff when
you're 15.
are you too trusting are you not
trusting enough are you walking around
paranoid at everyone are you always
freaking out and you're like I'm not
gonna do that I'm not going to
compromise so so you can end up there
are you risk averse or are you Reckless
you know I'm kind of breaking these
things into a dichotomy like you're
either or and some stuff you're cool
some stuff you're you're well balanced
which is great so you know you're well
balanced and you know that you're pretty
good at assessing risk and that's a good
thing to be okay cool so you can check
that one off you don't have to worry
about it too much and then you know when
it goes from life and then there's a
whole bunch of other things we could
talk about you know are you are you
careless with your money or are you too
Frugal with your mind some people some
people are so Frugal with their money
they're you know they die with you know
all this money in the bank yeah
and you know the the say the old saying
goes you can't take it with you right so
what do you do why didn't you go to the
free go to you know go and surf for a
weekend instead you were didn't want to
spend that gas money yeah so
figure out what your own tenancy is what
your own terrain is
and same thing with leadership
perspective are you a microman do you
tend to be a micromanager do you tend to
be obsessed with the details do you tend
to get emotional do you tend to get too
aggressive
and and then what you have to do is you
have to take those tendencies that you
have
and you have to
put them into the calculus of your
decision making
you have to you have to put that
denominator in there somewhere on your
formula to say yeah I know I'm super
hyped about this girl
but I also know that I get super hyped
about girls so before I make this step I
need to put that in the calculus
and here's the thing with all this
you're only going to be able to see it
if you're able to detach you're only
going to be able to
guys that are super and I keep on
bringing up guys that are super hyped on
girls why because in the teams bro you
get like you know the guy he meets the
girl yeah you know and it's just game on
I mean he's losing his mind he's just
going crazy about this girl
and you know you see did happen with
girls too those girls that would like Go
full uh what's the what's the movie
uh
full-on like they're just 27 Dresses no
no uh the girls tries to murder the guy
oh freaking fatal Fatal Attraction right
there's that too you know so you can get
all these things happening yes so these
are what we want to watch out for you
can't see that when you're when you are
in that zone
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
8.18 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance Jocko underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you mobilized
Underground